Anna welcome back to the studio what an
amazing Victory with the white pieces
and it started off uh slowly with that
idea of Queen B3 early on in the opening
tell us the story of that
idea okay uh I didn't expect this uh
line from Jennifer and uh I played I
think in first Ken cup versus har this
line but I completely forgot what I was
doing and in this lines it's great you
can just I can when theor play like
normal moves and in the middle just
general understanding so Queen B was
already no preparation I think she never
played Bishop before or I missed maybe
right and but you mentioned you played
this move Queen to B3 so she probably
should have known did I play I don't
remember I don't remember you
play in the no no she she played Bishop
before she played Bishop before but I I
I don't remember what I was doing got it
got it got it so this is game first Ken
scet for years ago right she got taken
back by this move Queen to B3 because
she thought for a while and then she
played this move Knight to C6 now the
game continued after that it looked like
some sort of a regoin situation uh but
perhaps a better regoin for you right
yeah yes and it was like many
interesting ideas which was behind the
scene instead of castline I consider it
E4 right away but then I just scared I
cannot explain why I didn't play E4
instead of Castle and for here maybe it
was better I was thinking E4 here yeah
here E4 I way it's interesting oh oh
okay it's not good no because of this
feel that I need to Queen A2 your sense
definitely played uh in your favor in
this one and now take advantage of this
bishop PA D3 with Knight G6 I see I see
yeah but General I have feeling that I
have to Castle first and then make
active actions in the middle no that was
the right right feeling for sure oh
could you please go back could you
please go back and I think for here it
was
interesting interesting to take on C4
and played Queen D5 and maybe F5 okay
and this was probably
better here yeah take take take and
queen D5 Queen E2 F5 to try to stop you
from playing E4 in the center yes yes or
play this position maybe with SP on A5
with was also possible maybe it's even
better to have Pawn on A5 of course like
I mean I mean instead on A4 to have this
position with black Pawn on A5 right
after Castle just take take and do the
same thing after Castle take take win D5
the same thing with spawn on A5 yeah I
thought it was better for her probably a
better option but still the game
continues the game is very very balanced
now where did you feel like you're
taking over the initiative at which
point did you feel secure in your initi
I was like secure I was after move only
after she took Pawn on D4 Rook takes D4
okay yeah because here was very
interesting I was not sure could you
please go back instead of okay oh plus
five I was right
yeah
yeah yeah because it was also very
interesting could like one move back and
uh so instead of Bishop takes F4 I was
thinking I spent a lot of time okay
Knight B3 thinking about Bishop H7 first
okay Bishop Bishop h seven King G8 and
uh Bishop takes F4 of course if Rook
takes F4 it's on my favor right to have
King on h8 but I didn't like Bishop F3
very good takes F3 and yes may maybe
bishop G3 here and Bishop G3 just Knight
A1 I didn't like
yes no that was very well I have I'm
exchange I should definitely have some
compensation okay Bishop F4 it's not the
move I want to play so so or maybe here
yes so that's why I was thinking I
should take Bishop F4 that's what I did
in the game but after after this option
she had this chance to play King f8
which of course was better than King h8
here Rook F6 yes Rooks F6 and I think I
would just play something normal like
Queen D3 oh wow I was on fire Queen D3
and just play I will have
compensation
yep great compensation have some
compensation great compensation maybe
more uh than just simple compensation
maybe you're just simply better right
now yeah much better I think it's like
computers say like small Advantage but
for human beings it's very hard to
defend especially we both run time
pressure yeah yeah and after Rook takes
D4 as you nicely pointed out after Rook
D4 I already thought might be winning
this is it somewhere yes yeah yeah and
you conducted the attack uh brilliantly
after that never gave her a chance to
get back into the game Anna
congratulations you had a great event at
the Ken's cup you're starting to pile up
some victories in this one are you
starting to have some dreams about
getting that National Championship once
again I'm trying not not not to dream
because sometimes when you dream when
you think about it you relax yes this is
my case so I'm like trying to be like
cautious and uh I'm trying to put less
pressure on myself because before I was
always fighting for like top top places
and now I just want to enjoy the game
continue playing and uh with less
pressure as is it used to be well keep
it up you're doing great
job thank you Anna I have just one quick
question for you if you don't
mind today you had this uh rather unique
experience you had more time on the
clock than your opponent your opponent
was in time
trouble this is actually only for couple
moves like entire game I was down on
down on time not at the end only by the
end yes unfortunately how did it feel to
see your opponent Str sometimes for me
I'm just like less confidence and I
cannot make decision and I'm afraid to
lose something okay when you like
blunder it like maybe I blunder at more
pieces than anyone in this tournament
maybe I like because I'm playing chess
for how many years right for 30 or even
more more than uh like most of the
players here live on
the and uh so I need to like force
myself to make a move to believe in my
calculations and I'm very happy after
such games I think I will uh I will be
more confident all right Anna thank you
very much uh and
congratulations by the way we're going
to be taking a